get up so we're still looking we're
still looking at a tie here so one of
the things which I wanted to mention was
once we've got the settings screen up
you've got a very custom settings
interface here and I can see why it's
it's relatively sort of custom
information but it's definitely
presented in a way that you wouldn't
expect yeah you wouldn't expect this
when you hit the Settings button so one
thing to consider is to see whether you
can sort of provide the same
functionality but within sort of the
more standard settings hierarchy see
hangover from like our one of our
earliest earliest versions and I think
it was one of those things we never
really changed or upgraded into how the
more standard way of doing things so
shun certain yeah it's definitely on our
road map of things to fix up excellent
excellent so I think you know just so
looking at the app in general I think
the biggest way that you're going to be
able to oh look they sort there's a good
button so let me let me ask you what the
quit button does which button quit if
you go settings there's a quick menu
option the quit button basically tells
the app to stop you know trying like so
it's going to stop all the services and
things like that to basically exit out
yeah and so this is as opposed that you
could have it playing and go and hit the
home button moon and it'd be kind of
like scanned or easy to Claire where
we'd still be playing the other thing we
wanted to give the user a quick button
so they could make sure you know is all
shut down okay so that's that's
reasonable what you might find is a is
actually a better alternative I see that
once you've got the once you've you've
got something playing you have an
ongoing notification which is absolutely
the right thing to do what you might
want to consider is modifying this so
that the user can pause directly from
that so your behavior here should be
pretty much the same as you would expect
from say google music or Spotify or
anything like that which is going to be
playing music
or any kind of audio in the background
the reality is that quit button it's
kind of meaningless you should always
assume that any app is going to be able
to intelligently continue in the
background or get killed in the
background without the user having to
sort of explicitly exit you know it's
one of my hot button topics this whole
notion of having an exit button it's
kind of confusing to users because it's
not a standard Android paradigm and it's
it's definitely ambiguous what does it
mean what exactly does it do so in this
instance I think you'd be better off
implementing it in the same way as music
so that when you hit pause effectively
the app is is stopped so if you if you
do have something on going in the
background you just bring down your
notification hit the stop button or the
pause button and that effectively does
the same thing as the the quit button
would do without necessarily the
explicit stop calls to the services and
activities yeah so other than that I'd
say that the stop and actually so other
than that let's say the biggest thing
that you can do to really give this app
which is already quite useful a little
bit more polish is just look at the
design guides on the developer site and
see if there are ways that you can sort
of easily implement a bunch of those so
things like the action bar things like
the viewpager you know to try and make
something which just looks and feels a
little bit more modern a little bit more
in touch with the sort of current
android style guides and i think that'll
have a really big impact so they are
these like our target platform right now
is uh is the sdk eight 2.2 froyo and so
like how many of the like because i
thought as the action bar is this
introduced later right it was that
either honeycomb or ICS i think right
yeah honey cone was the first place that
was seen but yeah I cs4 for phones
definitely so i guess like in that
regard like would you recommend like
trying to you know implement these
features for future you know platforms
as far as like ice cream sandwiches and
then like reflect to reflect to get the
functionality or would you just or is
there a better way to do it and still
kind of
have that 2.2 base yeah so I guess I
will do both so for the for the newest
releases for the Ice Cream Sandwich
phones them then you can just use the
the native components like the action
bar to get that effect we've actually
been promoting the same sort of general
sort of UI design for a while so there's
a lot of I mean the action bar it's just
one piece but it's sort of the overall
look and feel sort of the way it's all
put together you know if you follow the
ICS guidelines you'll end up with
something which still looks really good
it has great usability going all the way
back to Freya the only thing you'll have
to do yourself is to create basically an
action bar or use a third-party tool
like action Russia I like to simulate
the same sort of behavior but
fundamentally it's actually not that
hard you're just talking about a set of
use along the top which has the you know
the app title on the left navigation
over on that side and any actions on the
right hand side so you can actually
implement something which looks and
behaves they're very similar to an
action bar without too much extra work
so you know in the in this example you
would be doing that it would just be
helping to move some of these controls
into a more predictable place so these
actions would end up on the top and
everything else would drop down slightly
exactly how these these controls would
be implanted i think is kind of a more
challenging a UI question is something
that I think maybe Roman would have a
more opinion on but again you know
looking at similar apps like podcasting
apps or music apps and seeing how they
do the relatives split of information
that they could be really informative ok
so right oh I'm loathe to interrupt any
action bar conversation but I did want
to point out we have when on on
the Hangout as well creator of receipt
ninja ok so it would be right if we
could spare him a little time as well I
don't wear 140 cool let's uh let's split
across so that's I think that's pretty
much the cave of what we were gonna say
was there anything else i just wanted to
show real quick the tablet version here
basically you know the same type of
feedback these touch points are really
tiny see my fingers like just massive
come
um you have abnormally watching is that
to take into it and since you have you
know a really big tablet screen I mean
you should be able to utilize it and
make the buttons a little bigger and
just in general this this whole web view
thing I'm not actually sure what what
the value of it is since it's more of a
screen reader type app and I watch the
promo video on your Google Play thing
and it really promotes you know starting
it up and putting in your pocket and
just you know walk into the bus
listening to it in a car or something so
giving so much screen real estate just
for this web view that probably isn't
going to be looked at you know you might
want to rethink that and that's all I
had on top of your feedback yeah i would
say in burma makes a really good point
there if you are doing some text
extraction already on it you might be
better off just displaying the text
which you're actually going to read out
rather than the entire website certainly
provide a link as you have done but in
betting like anything might be overkill
okay well sort of us were 22 receipt
ninja thank you
hey blue hey that's gonna all right so
we're going to take out their receipt
ninja and we have the developer of
receipt ninja also on a hangout is that
right yeah hey I'll see you guys like I
can see you at the corner of my eye if
not out of the front so we've got a hero
up on the on the phone which we can take
a look at perfect so again this so this
is this is a point which we've made in
the past about apps which start up and
straight away asked you to rate the app
so i have started this a couple of times
so it's possible that it didn't do this
the first time but I have a vague
recollection that it did so this is this
is kind of tricky because I can't really
write an app that I haven't used yet so
we definitely recommend it if you are if
you do choose to encourage your users to
rate the app then to defer that until
the Middle East use the app a few times
now I think we set this up knowing that
already it's like seven times after you
use a sim her ok so you again for one of
the there's a couple of issues here as
well which i do want to take the time to
highlight as you say so it takes until
seven times you you have no way of
knowing whether or not I've already
raided our seat ninja so if I wrote so
if i have this is kind of spammy it's
like I've already rated you stop asking
me to write you a number and at the same
time as well it's you sort of the the
impetus here to ask people to rate your
app you know I understand that you you
work really hard on something and you
want people to you know to provide that
feedback to give you you know a great
rating if that's what they think it
deserves the reality is is the people
who are inclined to do those ratings
they just will it's it's not that they
just all I was I just forgotten if you
hadn't mentioned it then I wouldn't have
gotten around to it most of the people
who are inclined to already will so
again you sort of you sort of spamming
people who either will have done it
anyway or weren't really inclined just
to be able to get a couple more people
perhaps some small percentage which
which needed the prompting okay so so
you know for the for the fact that it
interrupts my flow it makes me have to
press an extra button before I launch
the app for all of those things I don't
that you're going to get the the right
return to make that worthwhile I've
actually seen bad ratings related to
something like this so it might actually
make it worse to pop something up like
this so that's something thing about to
yeah so if you do if you just if you
feel strongly that it's something that
you want to present your users i would
suggest do in on the flip side so at at
some point where it's not interrupting
the flow have it you know somewhere on
the screen where it's not interrupting
your workflow it's not an old st is all
right we'll move on all right so looking
at the app itself you've gone with the
the effect where you've got yeah sort of
a real-world sort of wood type look here
which is he's interesting it certainly
gives it a strong visual aspect there's
a couple of things to tell when I sort
of point off right off the bat looking
at this the first sort of feeling I get
is it doesn't quite feel like it's an
android app you've got these tabs along
the bottom you've got sort of this very
iphone looking button style along the
top and and on both sides so it kind of
has like it's obviously it's got its own
unique you why but it feels like it's
its own unique you I but tailored more
towards an iphone user so as an Android
user I feel a little like all wait this
doesn't quite look the way I would
expect okay yeah so was that it was that
a conscious choice I mean is this is
this an iphone port or did you develop
from scratch with this sort of actually
i derived from scratch yeah android
first and an iphone but i think it's
because the reason why i used that bar
is because i think it's more clear it's
a more straightforward yeah but do you
have any suggestions like if i want to
change into Android UI absolutely so we
we cover a lot of the sort of
suggestions i'm going to make in the
design site or the design guidelines on
developer.android.com a couple of the
key ones there is that generally tabs
for android belong up the top rather
than along the bottom is whether that's
tabs or some other kind of navigation
like a spin around an action bar
something like that we generally have
that of the top
towards the left I still wanted cheats
the top bar or the action bar so that I
can ask to have more like actions can be
performed on the same page chump so
again so you can you can totally do that
so again having the the events button so
that's kind of interesting so that whole
workflow is is kind of weird so what we
would generally expect on Android is the
top left is going to be some sort of
Home icon a logo something like that and
generally speaking pressing it is going
to take you back to the main screen of
your application so in your case it
would be here I would not expect the top
left to do anything the fact that here
so you've got you can choose between
different events presumably events which
you can then add expenses too yeah so
again like the the fact that you've got
new event as an option on a on a button
list is confusing to me because this is
an action but presented as a selection
so it's not really the way it should be
presented like anything which is going
to create something new should be
implemented as a button or something
like that which implies a user action
which is going to result in another
screen reason so I would yeah I would
probably move that out of there cee-ment
give the spelling okay so then it's gone
into that and so so what you've done
here with the navigation is reasonable
but here what I would expect is that
this would then become an icon with an
UP button so the pressing this would
take me back to the previous screen the
the main story if there is a main screen
and so here where you've got the
selection what you would do is have
these potentially as a spinner if you
have a look at the gmail app that's a
really good example of something which
allows you to choose between sort of
these different inboxes or different
labels so i would definitely check that
out the plus here that's that's
perfectly reasonable with the ability to
create that new receipt council save
this this is fine one
comments I would make I'm not one
hundred percent sure myself of the right
order the design guides explicitly call
out which side the confirmed versus
cancel buttons should be so it's worth
just confirming that you've got them in
the right place back button does what it
should do so that's all fine so I mean I
really I think you can get a long way
here just by modifying the navigation
structure and switching the tab so that
there along the top beneath your beneath
your action bar rather foggy bottom is
it and similarly with sort of some of
your icons again so particularly the
Settings icon looks a little like an
iPhone Settings button yeah and so
that's that's all fine again with this
that's interesting later so so one of
the things which I would point out here
as well in terms of navigation so
obviously these are tabs and so you're
right in that pressing back on a tab
shouldn't go to the previous tab it
should exit the app right that being
said those settings is not something I
would expect to be in a tab so from an
Android perspective I expect to change
my settings and then hit back to go back
into the application so i would consider
sort of modifying your settings screen
so that's using and more standard either
the standard settings framework or at
least behaving in a way that mimics the
standard settings framework okay of it I
notice also that you've got a menu
button so you're not targeting API level
14 or 15 no so it's not doing anything
so which actually turns it into a menu
button of shame because you've got the
menu button here but it doesn't you
don't need it you don't you don't have
an existing menu sort of hierarchy that
you need to implement on the new version
so you can you can get rid of that
simply by changing a tire but version of
the SDK everything else will continue to
work the way that it has done but the
little menu button will disappear which
is a bug that was a big one let's see I
don't think we're rapidly running out of
time so I don't think we really have
have time to go into sort of the
functionality in too much detail to do I
think you may have had a chance to look
at this last week is there anything
short and sharp we can
just from a tablet point of view first
of all it doesn't go to landscape mode
yes tablet interview is essentially very
big he's just very big phone view I go
to the tab love you yeah the job doesn't
ride out so uh thing I suggest is just
to use fragments and maybe make you know
this screen here when you add a new
receipt you know one side of the screen
of you of all the events and then you
select the event and on the other side
of the screen would be you know the
receipts for those events yeah absalom
so that be you know a little ice nicer
for the tablets because right now it's
just you know a lot of wasted space
right here you see just a bunch of wood
it's not so much yes well yeah yeah
that's a really good tip I mean a lot of
the times with you or you know any time
you've got sort of two levels of
navigation which you effectively do here
you've got the three tabs + the the
events to choose that's report time it's
interesting yeah so you've either got
the tabs and then you've got different
events the different report types and
all of those things so on a tablet you
can you can remove one additional layer
of navigation and that's often a really
good approach to how do you go to do I
is to remove one navigation layer yeah
ok so we're running out of time we want
to try and make sure that we can get the
games review up and running with
slightly finger technical difficulties
than we've experienced so what we're
going to send you some some specific
feedback as well as two other things
which we didn't get around to but thank
you very much for joining us on the yeah
yeah yeahs and read out the the
collective consciousness of the Internet
has asked me to ask you actually send
the feedback to you we do have two or
three developers that did not receive
anything from us so very well I
apologize for not getting on that and
sending it through to you more rapidly
we will definitely send that to you in
the next few days well next few days
after this long weekend so that you can
actually take advantage of some of the
advice that we've been getting
so yes apologies for the bear oh look
with the right way around how exciting
all right so we're going to sign off
thank you very much for joining us this
week and for persevering through the
technical difficulties hopefully we will
have fewer of those and more great apps
to review in the coming weeks we're
going to sign off stick around in and
actually not down in and Alex Alex yes a
replacement bearded friend will be